and so far more than 350 000 doses of
the kova 19 vaccine have gone out all
across our state
and there's another pop-up clinic this
morning to get shots to people who need
the most we have hector mejia live this
morning
in north las vegas with details on this
hi hector
hey there alex and it's all starting in
just an hour here at the mlk junior
senior center you do need an appointment
however
i have some good news for you step into
our mobile office on this website where
you make the appointment it shows
that there are still several time slots
available for tomorrow you can see
several time slots there
you just click on one and it takes you
to a different page where it asks for
your information
the pop-up clinic is offering the first
round of the pfizer vaccine to people
who are 70 and up
plus frontline and healthcare workers
the clinic opens today and tomorrow from
7 a.m to 2 p.m
one major concern for state leaders is
equity after learning that certain
minority groups are
not getting enough vaccines compared to
their percentage of the population
that's why they're focusing on this
governor steve sisselak recently
announced an initiative to change that
so those who qualify are interested in
receiving the shot here we'll need to
call
702-342-8417 to schedule an appointment
or as you just saw a few moments ago you
can also make an appointment online
and we have this information as well as
the link on our website already posted
eight newsnow.com
and the second shot will be given 21
days after receiving the first one and
still ahead of the next half hour we'll
go over the numbers released
by the southern nevada health district
that talk about the minority groups
falling behind here in the valley and
it's also a trend we're seeing across
the country
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now